We are here with Chloë Grace Moretz
who is starring in Tom and Jerry,
the new film which we're all so excited about as parents
who get to watch something new with our kids.
But that hearkens back to
not only the cartoons that we all grew up with
but I watch Tom and Jerry every day with my kids.
Why did you want to do this?
This is so exciting.
Thank you for this gift, Chloë.
Honestly, it makes me so happy
to hear you say exactly that.
You know, I grew up with Tom and Jerry
from the time I was a little, little girl.
My mom grew up with it from the time she was a little girl,
my brothers and I.
And so I really think it's one of those, you know,
cartoons that's really been
generationally in our lives for so long.
And I really jumped at the opportunity
to not only bring this piece back into the modern day
but also be able to do this live action, you know,
plus the animation kind of world,
similar to Roger Rabbit which I grew up with as well
and introduce it to young kids
that have never seen Tom and Jerry in at all.
You know what I mean, so it's a really fun, I think,
multi-generational project.
Bring on the chases.
It's like, it's funny!
Yeah I know, that's exactly it.
Bring on the antics, bring on the slapstick comedy.
And we filmed this back in 2019
which is, you know, pre the pandemic.
So I think now more than ever,
this is really the perfect movie to be coming out,
so we can all just sit together
and check out for a little while
and smile and laugh and not think about our day-to-day.
I just love this world
and I do think that people need more entertainment
in their homes that they can enjoy on their own
or with their kids or that their kids could enjoy.
We need that because we're all stuck at home together.
Yeah.
Okay Chloë,
I know this is going to sound like a weird segue,
but is it true?
Did you set up Meghan Trainor with her husband?
I just saw that.
Yeah, yeah.
(laughs)
Daryl Sabara was one of my closest friends
when we were, I was like 15 years old.
We did a Steven Soderbergh play together
called "The Library."
And years later I met Meghan
and we totally hit it off as friends.
And she was like, "I'm looking for a good guy."
And I was like, "Well, my very, very, very close friend
"is, you know, one of the nicest guys I've ever met.
"I think you guys would totally hit it off."
They hit it off.
They fell madly in love and now they have a baby,
which is crazy.
It's like a true, a true match made in heaven.
That is so cool.
Do you know how many girls out there are so happy?
'Cause like, wouldn't so many people
love to have their friend have their back
and be like, "Let's try this."
Matchmaking is such a wonderful thing.
It's so wonderful.
Sometimes it totally blows up in your face.
I've done it a few times where like,
they've not hit it off and I'm like, "I'm so sorry."
But with this one, it really was one of those just like,
perfect, you know, serendipitous things.
And it's been so wonderful to see their relationship
bloom and blossom.
And now with a new life, it's just, I mean--
and his birthday, he's four days after mine.
So it was crazy.
He was born four days after me.
And I was like, what is going on here?
It all sounds so serendipitous and beshert and perfect.
Are you gonna match-make again
now that you're like amazing at it?
And, who cares, some don't work out.
That's life, you know, but are you gonna try it again?
I mean, let's see.
Let's see if I can, if I can keep my batting average high,
you know what I mean?
I'm trying to try to keep it there.
Chloë, I think everything you touch turns to gold.
So, whether it's a film or just getting to work with you
and know you and be your friend
or it's setting up couples that's gonna change their life,
I think you can do it all, of course.
(laughs) Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I'm gonna try, I'm gonna try.
Oh, Baby Flee, 'cause that's what we were.
Mama Flee and Baby Flee making a beautiful short film
that some of the best directors I've ever known,
Steven Spielberg and Martin Scorsese have been like,
we love this.
I'm like Chloë, you and I made something
that impressed the two greatest filmmakers
ever to live on planet earth.
I know, I know, which is wild.
I definitely think we should try and do it again.
And this time, maybe a full link.
As soon as possible, Chloë Grace.
In fact, we're going to put the short film
in its full length up on TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
So if you want to look at something
that I was lucky enough to make with Chloë,
we'd love to share it with you.
Chloë Grace Moretz, Tom and Jerry premiers today.
Thank you, it couldn't come soon enough
in select theaters and HBO Max where it's all happening.
Baby Flee, I love you, I'm so happy to see you.
Thank you for coming on the show.
(upbeat music)